la violencia desatada en el noroeste de
Brasil continúa escalando en la última
noche Se registraron nuevos incendios y
la destrucción de inmuebles como
oficinas vehículos mercados y hasta una
gasolinera un problema que preocupa
severamente a los habitantes de 19
localidades del estado de Río Grande de
un Norte mayo que está contagiando nunca
había visto algo así en mi vida salimos
a trabajar no recibimos nada y nos
encontramos en una situación como ésta
es muy triste esta situación es muy
triste
esa situación
no me siento totalmente insegura pero te
das cuenta que la situación es muy
peligrosa fuimos a natal a caminar y no
pudimos conseguir un Uber Para volver no
íbamos a tomar un taxi de regreso era
bastante peligroso
según manifestaron las autoridades estos
ataques han sido ordenados por
pandilleros que están dentro de la
cárcel más grande de la región como
consecuencia a un endurecimiento en las
políticas internas y rechazos a pedidos
de los reclusos
esta semana el gobierno desplegó más de
220 efectivos de la guardia nacional
pero no fue suficiente para apaciguar la
situación
los vecinos dicen que aquí hubo un
ataque con fuego en la puerta de la
comisaría y que hubo muchos tiros 12
tiros
desde el comienzo de la violencia al
menos tres civiles murieron en tanto que
decenas de personas fueron detenidos
mientras en algunas ciudades las
escuelas debieron suspender las clases
por temor a más ataques y se
interrumpieron otros servicios como el
sistema Público de transporte